he's making copies offering how do we do  this shot right there clothesline I  bother we try to swab the dough handle  right now keep in touch with Laura on  the phone make sure he's not walking out  swab it though hang on and get this done  once they hit the roadway they had no  expectation of privacy I'm gonna get on  the phone right now you know I'm I'm a  long way from next for technology and  I've said that before but I feel help me  find out who he's use your neighs murder  yes so dog rather than go to school and  learn some new tricks maybe we're doing  it right now  all right so let me know we're good what  he looks like right now  we still good  he's walking away from the copier I  think he's headed back to the car good  good killing fields the gripping season  finale Tuesday at 10:00 on discovery